i flew to la this weekend here's a
really good question i got while i was
there hey gary my name is irma when you
were working with your dad and helping
build this company you literally got
paid zero did you ever resent that in
the beginning and how long did it take
you to really appreciate that process my
dad paid me two bucks an hour in my
teenage years 18 and older i was getting
minimum wage and then from 20 to 32 i
was always very undercompensated because
it was a family business there was times
where i was like this sucks it was hard
because i was such an impact on the
business and i was getting
undercompensated i would have been
better off working at a company rising
up the ranks and got paid properly but
it was never resentment because it was
micro frustration but in the macro i was
so grateful that my parents brought me
to america to live the american dream so
me working my face off for the family
felt appropriate i was in a selfless
place and then when i wanted to do
something for myself i took on
responsibility and accountability i
couldn't change the family business
dynamics and make my dad do something i
went out and did something for myself
i'm grateful for what he did for me but
i was micro-fry stranded at times